dans le dossier du sang contaminé à
présent la décision hier de la cour de
justice de la république n'a pas fini de
susciter des réactions
la relaxe de laurent fabius et de
georgina dufoix et la condamnation sans
peine d'edmond hervé ne satisfont
personne ni la classe politique ni les
victimes des victimes qui attendent
maintenant la tenue d'un troisième
procès qui se peut qu'ils pourraient se
dérouler dans les deux ans à venir
les familles espèrent obtenir des
explications 2000 verdeilhan hier après
midi les deux associations de transfuser
d'hémophiles avoué se tourner vers le
prochain procès celui qui jugera les
médecins et les conseillers ministériels
vont attention je crois ferme de
travailler ensemble parce qu'il serait
dommage que dans une procédure aussi
difficile avec en face des mis en examen
puis s'en extrait souvent solidaires on
l'a vu lors du procès des ministres ne
puissions pas nous victimes essayé de
présenter un front relativement commun
en tout cas au niveau des associations
déjà jugé déjà condamné michel garretta
fait partie des 32 personnes mises en
examen pour complicité d'empoisonnement
devant la cour de justice il fut simple
témoin et plaident à l'erreur collective
autres accusés condamnés en 93
jacques roux ancien directeur général de
la santé indignés par la tenue d'un
troisième procès on a dit maintenant on
va attendre le prochain procès n'est ce
pas qui sera le grand pont c'est mon
avis ap ap le plus grand que les autres
et je crois que ni la justice ni le
pouvoir politique ne gagneront et ne ne
gagnerons a autorité en crédibilité en
continuant à faire comme ça les choses
par petits morceaux en attente d'être
jugé claude wassenberg ancien conseiller
technique d'edmond hervé devant la cour
de justice
il refusa purement et simplement de
témoigner actuel pdg de renault louis
schweitzer à l'époque des faits il était
le directeur de cabinet de laurent
fabius françois gros ancien conseiller
technique de laurent fabius
à la barre il avait dédouané l'ancien
premier ministre
j'ai bien entendu que l'action du
premier min avec une décision rapide est
donc un processus décisionnel
on n'a pas perdu de temps et je pense
vraiment que la même appréciation ne
manquera pas d'être donnée pour fraude
et sans france par ce troisième dossier
n'est toujours pas clos et compte tenu
des délais de procédure le procès ne
devrait pas avoir lieu avant la fin de
l'an 2000